Now that we understand the" happened before" relationship
and the transitivity of" happened before" relationship. I also
want to introduce this notion of concurrent events.
That is, concurrent events are events in which there
is no apparent relationship between the events. So,
for instance, I'm showing you two nodes of the
disterbent system. A is an event on one node, and b is an event on another node,
and you can see that since a and b are not events on the same node we cannot
apply the sequential process condition to say that there
is an ordering between a and b, and by the
same token, since a is an event here, b
is an event here And there is no communication between
these two guys that connections these events in any
shape or form, either directly or transitively. There is no
ordering between a and b, and therefore these two
events are concurrent events, not sequential events, not connected
where they happened before relationship, but they're concurrent events.
So, in other words, We cannot say anything about
the ordering of a and b in the distributed
system. So, this is the fun thing about a
distributed system is that has "Happened Before" relationship which
looks at either events on the same process or
events across process is connected by communication and
the transitivity of "Happened Before" relationship Through the native
happened-before relationships give at best a partial order
for all the events that are happening in the
system, so there's no way for us to
derive a total order by looking at the events
that are happening on the same process or just
looking at the events that are happening on the
different processes. In the distributed system and this is
a very good example why it's impossible to get a
total order for all the events that are happening
in the distributed system. Because there are events they are
going to be concurrent, that's the nature of the
game that these procesors are executing asynchronously with respect to
one another and therefore The event that is happening
over here. You know, if I want to look at wall
clock time in one execution of the distributed program,
it's possible that a in real time, happened before
b but the same program when I execute it
again, the second time around, it could be that
this event b happened before a. And therefore, these
2 events are called concurrent events. So the important
point about these concurrent events that happened before relationship
is that And structuring a distributed algorithm. It's important to
recognize what events are connected by the
happened before relationship, and what events are concurrent
events, and once you have an understanding
of these two concepts, then you can build
robust distributed systems and robust applications. Because
if you have any assumptions about the ordering
of events that are unconnected by communication like
this, that can lead to an erronious program.
So one of the bane of distributed programs
is synchronization and communication bugs and timing bugs. And
this is a classic example. Of a timing bug
that you can have if you mentally think that
A happened before B and that's the way you
want it to happen. It may not happen. Because
these two events are concurrent events. Now that I've
introduce to you all important basics of events and
ordering of events in distributed system. It's time for another quiz.